Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David Hart's Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with the truth about why Senate
Bill 2230 the Muslim Brotherhood
terrorist designation act must be passed
this is not just an option it's a
necessity to bring sanity back to US
foreign and domestic policy if anyone
should know whether or not the
Brotherhood is a terrorist organization
it is those who have borne the brunt of
its wrath thus it was Illuminating when
Coptic solidarity a group dedicated to
defending the rights of one of the
Egyptian Muslim brotherhood's Chief
Terror targets began an advocacy
campaign in favor of the Muslim
Brotherhood terrorist designation act
Coptic solidarity president Alex shalabi
declared it is unconscionable that the
US still has not taken this action when
countries such as Egypt Syria Russia the
UAE and South Saudi Arabia have all
declared the Muslim Brotherhood to be a
terrorist
organization this delay is solely the
responsibility of the powerful friend of
the Muslim Brotherhood who lives in the
White House Barack Obama Barack Obama
made sure that Muslim Brotherhood
members were in the audience when he
gave his Cairo speech in June 2009 and
came out in favor of the uprisings
against Egypt's President hne Mubarak
even when it became clear that the
Brotherhood stood to be their chief
beneficiary protesters against the
Brotherhood regime in Egypt as it was
driven from power in 2013 accused Obama
of supporting terrorism the accusation
was not made lightly during the
brotherhood's one year in power Egypt's
El Nadim Center for rehabilitation of
victims of violence documented 359 cases
of torture by the regime 10 times the
number of cases documented annually
during the Mubarak regime one Chief
Brotherhood Target was Egypt's Christian
Community Brotherhood partisans
ransacked Christian businesses and
abducted Christian children Brotherhood
members blamed the fall of their regime
on the Christians and rampaged through
Egypt rampaging against Christians
burning and looting nearly 70 churches
and destroying a thousand Christian
businesses and homes the Reverend Khalil
FY of kazer Al duara Evangelical Church
the middle east's largest Evangelical
Church said the Muslim Brotherhood were
the ones who called for aggression
against Christians they are responsible
either they are in control or they burn
Egypt this violence however was just an
intensification of the ongoing low-level
persecution to which the Brotherhood
subjected the Christians for years as
far back as
2003 the US Commission on International
religious freedom said that Coptic
Christians face ongoing violence from
vigilin Muslim extremists including
members of the Muslim Brotherhood many
of whom act with impunity the Muslim
Brotherhood terrorist designation act
itself sets out ample evidence that the
Brotherhood richly deserves the terror
designation including February 2011
testimony by then FBI director Robert
Mueller who declared that elements of
the Muslim Brotherhood both here and
overseas have supported terrorism
Richard Clark the former National
coordinator for National Security and
counterterrorism said in 2003 the issue
of terrorist financing in the United
States is a fundamental example of the
shared infrastructure level levered by
Hamas Islamic Jihad and Al-Qaeda all of
which enjoy a significant degree of Co
degree of cooperation and coordination
within our borders the common link here
is the extremist Muslim Brotherhood all
of these organizations he said are
descendants of the membership and
ideology of the Muslim Brothers now when
he said that Clark was right Al-Qaeda
Founders Abdullah aam and Usama Bin
Laden and its current leader IM zahiri
were all members of or trained by the
Muslim Brotherhood this support for
Jihad terror is in line with the
brotherhood's goal since its founding
Brotherhood founder Hassan albana's
ambition was to restore the caliphate
which had been abolished in 1924 four
years before he founded the Brotherhood
creating a global Islamic superstate
instituting Sharia as Islamic law ALB
insisted that it was a duty incumbent on
every Muslim to struggle it is Jihad
towards the the aim of making every
people Muslim and the whole world
Islamic so that the banner of Islam can
flutter over the earth and the call of
the muine can ReSound in all the corners
of the world Allah abbar now that of
course includes the United States
Brotherhood leader Muhammad MTI Annam AK
said in 2004 I have complete faith that
Islam will invade Europe and America he
was referring not to a military Invasion
but one driven by Propaganda on Obama's
watch that propaganda has spread far and
wide giving the Brotherhood a mantle of
respectability one secular Muslim noted
in 2015 most Americans do not know how
vicious and bloody the Muslim
Brotherhood is they really don't
understand it's time they do the terror
designation will enable the next
president and Congress to move
decisively against the Brotherhood maybe
just in the nick of time I'm Robert
Spencer